ce week-end à vacciner ses deux premiers
enfants qui sont maintenant âgés de 15
et 10 ans mais pas la petite dernière
qui a 4 ans un choix motivé par les
effets secondaires qu'il dit avoir
subies alors qu'elle s'est fait vacciner
contre l'hépatite
en 2008 elle a souffert de graves
problèmes gastro intestinaux et dit
avoir contracté la maladie de crohn même
si cela n'a pas été confirmé par son
médecin elle reste persuadée que ses
propres problèmes de santé il est
trouble d'apprentissage de ses deux
aînés ont été causés par les vaccins
elle serait même excusé auprès de ses
deux enfants
elle fait partie de ces anti vaccins
tout comme jo world il y a cinq ans il a
fondé le mouvement de résistance au
vaccin
bien que n'ayant aucune formation
scientifique ou médicale
il fait partie de ces révolutionnaires
qui dénoncent ce qu'ils appellent le
lobby des pharmaceutiques et la
propagande médias en faveur des vaccins
c'est le corps qui peut se battre tout
seul contre les maladies dit il il est
d'ailleurs profondément convaincu qu'il
y a un lien entre l'autisme et les
vaccins contre la rougeole les oreillons
et la rubéole une croyance basé sur une
seule étude réalisée par ce médecin
britannique
elle joue avec fait au bout en 1998 la
recherche réalisée auprès de 12 enfants
seulement a été publiée par la revue
scientifique de 27
seul problème après enquête elle s'est
avérée frauduleuse et wakefield a été
radié brian ward est la bête noire du
mouvement antivaccin il est de ceux qui
ont démonté le mythe de cette étude
notamment pour le compte du département
américain de la justice
il constate que cette croyance persiste
chez les anti vaccin ça parce qu'ils
n'ont pas d'autres publications parce
qu'il n'y a personne à part de wakefield
et quelques-uns de ses collègues qui
croient qu'il y à une loi
ce n'est qu'en 2010 que la recherche été
retirés de la publication scientifique
et le mal était fait le taux de
vaccination a chuté et les cas de
rougeole ont augmenté au royaume-uni et
aux etats-unis depuis le mouvement
antivaccin à bourgeonner davantage pas
étonnant que les nouveaux cas de
rougeole en californie ces dernières
semaines et fait réagir la maison
blanche
il est irresponsable dit le porte parole
d'obama de ne pas vacciner ses enfants
car le vaccin est efficace selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
entre 2000 et 2013 l' oms estime que la
vaccination antirougeoleuse à éviter
plus de 15 millions de décès à travers
le monde au canada depuis 1924 la
vaccination a d'ailleurs permis de
réduire considérablement le nombre de
cas ottawa déplore le mouvement
antivaccin les anti vaccins dit elle met
en danger la santé des autres enfants
un message aussi à l'attention des
parents de la vallée du fraser en
colombie-britannique
là où 30% des enfants de moins de deux
ans ne sont toujours pas à jour en
termes de vaccination
une vaccination qui demeure sur une base
volontaire
il y a des petits pas chiant à cause des
croyances religieuses qui ne croient pas
dans les vaccinations à mais on respecte
des opinions divergentes l'an passé
notamment à cause de ses croyances la
rougeole avait quand même toucher
environ 400 personnes dans la région
mais les anti vaccin reste convaincu
possible de changer et vivent une
expérience d'ailleurs joué lors de lui
croit même que le dr wakefield sera
réhabilité une geekette elle continue
aussi son combat même si elle passe pour
une folle dit elle aux yeux des autres
parents ici frédéric arnould radio
canada vancouver